à l'origine de france miniature deux
visages tout est parti d'un projet
d'étude au moment où les parcs de
loisirs devenait un vrai sujet en france
thierry col qui a souhaité ancrer un
d'un genre différent
à l'époque étudiant en économie et droit
du tourisme france miniature est devenu
son cas d'application concret son
associé alain perez ancien ingénieur
passionné de trains miniatures est
arrivé sur le projet par sa passion du
modélisme ferroviaire
le projet a été entièrement réalisée sur
fonds privés
un investissement de 20 millions d'euros
objectif promouvoir le patrimoine à
l'architecturé créer un lieu culturel et
récréatif des murs vides de promouvoir
d'expliquer la part de douala de mettre
en en évidence la diversité des paysages
aux régions françaises le projet crée
une carte de france 2 5 ha en i mode lan
les reliefs rivières fleuves mers et
océans à l'échelle 1 2 centièmes
le projet a nécessité 18 mois pour
réunir le financement et les
autorisations administratives
on a lieu aussi à 18 mois au parti au 17
mai à shanghai roger modeler les plages
lancé en même temps la réalisation de
maquettes la réalisation et l'animation
de quelques trames un peu otc et 18 mois
l'installation à sa création le parc
disposer d'une équipe de maquettiste en
interne pour réaliser les villages et
installer les maquettes au sein de leur
écrin paysages et les monuments ont été
réalisées à l'échelle 1 30e par une
soixantaine d'artisans partout en france
à l'époque difficile à d'avoir des plans
opérationnels des bâtiments ils ont dû
faire des photos sur site des relevés et
tracer leur propre plan effectivement à
l'époque où les faits demande à voir les
outils que demain aujourd'hui les
imprimantes
je soutiens sa contribution des sont
assistés par les temps qui ont précédé
l'ouverture l'équipe a travaillé nuit et
jour pour finaliser l'installation le 25
mai 1991 le parc ouvre ses portes
thierry col qui s'en souvient c'est une
fierté de ce que le soulagement dans un
effort au monde des netbooks équipés
équipe avec une charrette manière solide
avec toujours bon sur le véhicule de
dire nous rêver parce que sa valeur des
visiteurs il y en a le parc en attire
plus de 200000 chaque année depuis 30
ans il fait désormais partie du paysage
culturel et daisy blinn mais aussi d'île
de france